Luke here at the outdoor boys YouTube
channel and today I'm gonna show you how
to tie the coolest knots so this video
isn't about the strongest knots it isn't
about the most useful knots this video
is about the coolest knots the knots
that are quirky that are fun to tie fun
to show off to do interesting things if
you want to see a video with my favorite
knots check out the link in the
description and if you want to see a
video with my favourite fishing knots
check out that link in the description
we've got lots of not videos but this
one is about cool knots knots that are
interesting and the first one I'm going
to show you is the flying bowline or the
tugboat bowline the flying bow line or
the tugboat bowline is a different not
than the standard bowline you learned in
Boy Scouts
however this knot serves the same
function it creates a loop that doesn't
collapse in on itself so then if you
need to wrap it around something it'll
keep a strong loop that won't close in
on itself
however it's not particularly useful
because you can't feed the line through
something it's only good when you can
place the loop over something so if you
wanted to make a loop on the end of a
line to throw it with somebody who's
drowning that works really well and the
name the tugboat bowline comes from the
fact that when you want to more up your
boat or you want to tow something you
can put a loop on the end of line fasten
it on to the dock or another boat and
pull with it it's very quick very easy
but a limited function there's a couple
ways to do the flying bowline but the
easiest way is to step on the working
end with your left foot and then grab
the bitter end or tag end with your
right hand you pull up a bite or a loop
of rope with your left hand and you wrap
it around and now you have two loops one
in your left hand one on your right hand
take the one in your right hand and feed
it through the loop in your left hand
and then pull holding the tag in and the
working end in the
right hand and then you pull it tight
and there you go this is what the knot
should look like when it's dressed
properly see on the back looks like this
and on the front it looks like so well
guys I told you the standard bowline and
the flying bowline we're a little bit
different so here you go this right here
is the flying bowline or the tugboat
bowline and this right here is the
standard bowline and you can see they
are very similar but they are definitely
different knots the tag end comes out in
a different angle and a different
location but they serve the same purpose
now obviously that was pretty quick so
let me show you one more time step on
the working end make a loop with your
left hand flick the tag end around the
loop place the loop in your right hand
through the loop in your left hand hold
the tag in the working end and you want
right hand and pull it tight
now if you have a six-year-old daughter
you want to impress you can tell her I
know how to do the knot from wanna now
you can't talk about the tugboat bowline
without talking about the one-handed
bowline so the idea is that if you're
drowning or need rescuing and somebody
throws you a rope and you need to tie a
bowline around yourself while holding on
to the rope so this rope attached to the
tree represents the rope attached to my
rescuers and I'm holding on to it with
one hand for dear life and I reach back
behind myself and wrap it around my body
okay step one so step two is that you
come over and wrap your hand around like
so in the rope now you don't want to do
it on your wrist you want to do it
around your hand and there's a very
important reason for this you'll see
later the step three is you take and
wrap the tag end around the main line
and you pull your hand through then you
could just lean into it and you've got
your bowline now the reason why you want
to wrap this loop around your hand and
not your wrist is that when you're
trying to back it through if the if it's
around your wrist it tightens up on you
and then you can't get your hand out
okay and then if you got to take use two
hands to get your hand out of the loop
all right let me show you that again
from a different angle you come over and
you make a loop around your fingers you
wrap the bitter end
around the working end and pull it back
through the hole then just lean into it
to tighten it up alright tell me you
want to watch me do this not quickly all
right we're gonna do it one more time
quickly
all right so another really cool knot I
think is not really a knot but a rope
system
it's the Swiss harness it's the way that
you can take a length of rope and turn
it into a climbing or rappelling harness
so let me show you how it works
to tie this with harness you're gonna
want a minimum of 12 feet of rope and
then you're gonna want to find the
middle of the rope and put a bite in it
then put that bite on the hip that's
opposite from your dominant hand so if
you're right-handed you put the bite on
your left hip then what you do is you
match these around okay you got both tag
ends in front and you're gonna tie a 1
overhand loop and then you're gonna tie
a second overhand loop and you'll make
that nice and tight then you're gonna
come out between your legs and you're
going to bring this up under the harness
and then
well and secure that then you're gonna
repeat the process tightening the rope
keeping it nice and tight under here
then under the rope
like that then once you have this big
long tag in you bring it across the
front and you tie it off over here
there you go that's the Swiss harness
right there folks and then you can
attach a rope right here on this part or
a carabiner and use it to repel or to
lift somebody let me know is that tight
enough that okay now here's the trick
with the harness is these aren't the
most comfortable harnesses in the world
but if you have a piece of wood and you
put it right there it it makes it not so
bad
see how's that now as you guys may have
noticed I am the father of several young
boys and one thing about little kids is
their shoelaces
never ever stay tied and so I'm going to
show you a really awesome alternative to
the traditional bow that's just as easy
to tie just as easy to untie but won't
come undone okay let me show you how to
tie shoes so they don't come undone this
is very very similar to the traditional
bow method let's do a simple overhand
knot the tight make a bite or a loop and
then you wrap it around once then wrap
it around twice and then tighten it up
and dress the knot
see there you go it looks exactly the
same
it comes out exactly the same but the
force needed to undo it is about double
alright so let me show you one more time
do a simple overhand knot tighten it up
make a loop come around just like a
traditional knot and then feed that loop
one more time through and then there you
go
and it works just the same but it
tightens up so much better here Nathan
why don't you pull that can you pull
that loose see it's a little hard for
him but I can do it alright next let me
show you the project knot now the prusik
knot is cool because of what it does the
prusik knot will slide up and down a
length of rope but as soon as you put it
under tension it locks into place and it
doesn't want to move so it allows you to
just it's location on a rope until it's
loaded up climbers like to use this rope
as kind of a do-it-yourself ascender it
also can be good for attaching little
side bits of rope so if you've got a
line strung between two trees and you
want to another line coming off that
works good for that and then you can
adjust it there's a number of different
uses for the project not and there's a
couple different ways to tie it so let
me show you two different ways to tie
the prusik knot the first and most
common way to tie the prusik knot
involves using a short bit of rope you
either tie the ends of the rope together
to make a big loop or you can just bend
it over in half and form a Bight and you
put the Bight over the rope you pull out
the tag ends and you feed them over once
twice and then like so and that
is the prusik not all right now let me
show you how to tie the prusik knot
using a long length of rope go and take
the rope and feed it once twice over and
take it in front of the working end then
come it over the top once twice three
times over and then dress it there you
go
that is the prusik knot and it'll slide
up and down no problem and as soon as
you tighten it up won't slide any more
the prusik knot is super cool one of the
coolest things you can do with it is
make a set of boasts men's handcuffs or
paracord handcuffs and you can do this
using about 36 inches of paracord
basically what you do is you take the
length of paracord and you tie a prusik
knot around your pointer finger okay and
just wrap it around like so dress it up
and make it look pretty get it all nice
and even pull it off like that then you
take one of the tag ends and you feed it
through and you take the other tag end
and you feed it through like so then all
you've got to do is just tighten up the
knot and dress it okay to start pulling
these two bits of line alright so there
you go there's a set of paracord
handcuffs just stick your hands in
through both sides like this and then
you pull these tag ends and the harder
you pull the tighter it gets
be careful playing around with these
things is they are handcuffs that don't
have key
Nathan you do it you're in jail you
can't get out of it your ankle
oh you're trapped for good oh I'll get
it off don't worry buddy
those handcuffs are no joke so those
look get on really tight
so be careful with that all right guys
let me show you another super cool not
this is a knot I featured in my videos
before it's the chain Senate not the
chain Senate not simply involves you
making a loop and then pulling a loop
through it and then pulling a leather
loop through it and then pulling another
loop through it okay making a chain of
loops that can be quickly undone now I
featured the chain Senate not before and
I've showed how it's really useful for
storing electrical cords long ropes
other things to the fabulous knot but
what you might not know is that there
are many many uses for the chain Senate
knot and this is what makes the chain
sit it not so cool so let me show you
one of the great uses for the chain
Senate knot
this right here is a paracord wrapped
axe handle it's 550 paracord and this is
what we call quick deploy paracord so I
can just undo this knot here at the
bottom and the whole thing will come off
in seconds giving me access to about 30
feet of paracord in addition to wrapping
ax handles you can use the chain Sinnott
not to create almost anything your
imagination can dream up the chain
Senate knot is basically what they use
when they do crocheting so you can make
paracord bracelets using the chain
Senate not you can make paracord
blankets you can make bags you can make
a hat out of paracord using the chain
Sinnott not pretty much anything you
wanted you could make using the chain
syn it not it is an extremely versatile
knot and it can be undone by simply
pulling the tag and well guys I hope you
enjoyed getting knotted with me if you
like this video check out
our knot-tying playlist on the outdoor
boys youtube channel we've got all our
different knot-tying videos and also
check out many of our other great
playlists including forging projects axe
restoration videos and fun videos with
the kids if you like what you see don't
forget to click subscribe the outdoor
boys puts out new videos every week and
we got a little something for everyone
thanks for watching guys thanks for
watching we hope you guys enjoyed this
video if you'd like to see more great
videos from the outdoor voice youtube
channel don't forget to click subscribe
we put out new videos every week and
don't forget to hit that Bell button so
you'll get notified when we put out
another great video